[Música]
ah
no
[Aplausos]
todos absolutamente todos tuvimos un
sueño que no pudimos cumplir
ya sea por falta de recursos o porque
nuestras capacidades físicas o
sensoriales no lo permitieron los invito
a pensar por un momento en ese sueño
llamémoslo frustrado
yo por ejemplo quería ser azafata
pero pues nadie se imaginaría una
azafata ciega o sí
no creo
mi condición de personas ciegas me llevó
a buscar otras alternativas de vida
ciegas
esa palabra que al principio no entendía
esa palabra que me resultaba tan
dolorosa cuando mis compañeritos me la
gritaban en el patio del colegio y yo
apunto de llorar y con desesperación me
tocaban los ojos y les gritaban no no yo
no soy ciega yo puedo ver
poco a poco y con el apoyo de mi familia
fui entendiendo lo que me sucedía y es
por eso que hoy en día uso de forma
natural la palabra ciega y otras como
ver o mirar
es tanta la naturalidad que por ejemplo
a veces estoy leyendo o redactando algo
y olvidó encender la luz porque pues
como no la veo
y llegó a mi papá o mi hermana y me dice
ahí se va a fregar los ojos
la discapacidad visual no ha limitado mi
curiosidad para conocer el mundo
en la niñez esa curiosidad me llevó a
pensar por ejemplo que los músicos y
cantantes estaban metidos en el radio y
los actores en el televisor yo pegado a
la oreja hacían al parla el parlante oa
la pantalla
a ver si los ubicaba en un intento por
sacarlos de allí acabe con un televisor
y dos grabadoras que mis papás tuvieron
la gentileza de no cobrar me ojalá no se
acuerden ahorita no
también desde pequeña me gusta hablar
por teléfono como estoy segura a muchos
de ustedes les pasó sin sospechar que en
el futuro terminaría trabajando
precisamente en el área de tecnología y
comunicaciones
como ha sido el caso de muchas personas
ciegas desde pequeña se me despertó el
interés por la música componía canciones
cantaba todo el día y hacía música con
todo lo que tenía al frente cuando digo
todo eso absolutamente todo la mesa la
loza los juguetes por eso a los 8 años
mis padres decidieron matricularme en el
conservatorio de la universidad nacional
conservatorio
la sola palabra a esa edad me asustaba
mucho y el lugar aún más recuerdo que
los salones eran fríos
tenía un olor como la construcción
antigua y los profesores eran muy
estrictos tenía clases casi todos los
días y mi madre siempre me acompañaba
incluso aprendió a leer música para
dictar me las partituras y es una
crítica musical que ustedes ni se
imaginan
ella puede no haber escuchado lo que
estoy tocando pero siempre siempre sabe
cuando me equivoco
las clases en el conservatorio al tiempo
con el colegio eran una carrera de la
casa al colegio del colegio el
conservatorio del conservatorio a la
casa y llegar por la noche hacer tareas
confieso que a veces odiaba el
conservatorio porque prácticamente no
tenía vida social pero sobre todo porque
no me daba tiempo para una de las cosas
que más disfrutaba jugar ponchados
escondidas y hasta fútbol con mis primos
estoy segura que todos jugaron con los
primos
pero esa disciplina que parecía tan
estricta al principio dio sus frutos
recuerdan esa bonita sensación cuando
recibieron su primer sueldo
eso mismo experimenté yo en mi grado de
bachiller a los 18 años tuve mi primer
toque pago
pero también a esa edad vive un momento
muy difícil frustrante
imagínense una joven de 18 años
recibiendo esta noticia del oftalmólogo
cuando nos dijo mi madre a mí que no
había nada que hacer y que yo nunca
podría ver
luego en un proceso aún más difícil y
fue acostumbrarme al bastón
el primer bastón que tuve me lo trajeron
de eeuu junto con un juego de cartas
saben que dice cuando lo recibí tomé el
juego de cartas el bastón no tire a un
lado lo que voy a salir con ese palo en
la calle qué vergüenza que eran mis
amistades
pero luego ese palo me permitiría ser
más independiente de la universidad los
que ya pasaron están pasando por esa
sabrán que cuando uno llega a la
universidad quiere por así decirlo
comerse el mundo y yo no era la
excepción pronto empecé a desplazarme
sola iba de rumba o a conciertos y
obviamente me empezaron a interesar los
muchachos
elegí como carrera filología e idiomas
siempre me ha gustado el sonido de otras
lenguas aunque no entendieran lo que
decían
y desde pequeña había aprendido
canciones en inglés ya está mermado mis
películas con las tres o cuatro palabras
que sabía
fue también en la época universitaria
donde llegó a mi vida el metal
[Música]
esa joven que ven ahí tocando el teclado
toda es peluca era yo
al principio fue difícil para mi familia
en especial para mi madre pero luego me
acompañaba a los toques sin problema
tocar en grupos de metal representó un
gran reto no sólo en lo musical sino
porque ingresé a un mundo
tradicionalmente dominado por hombres
recuerdo de manera especial un toque en
málaga santander en el que uno de los
asistentes me dijo que energía cuídese
esa melena
era un músico más como cualquier otro la
discapacidad allí simplemente no existía
no estaba la discapacidad
volviendo al tema de mi carrera
universitaria ya casi al final y más por
necesidad que por gusto debo decirlo
empecé a utilizar la tecnología hasta
ese momento había dependido de mi
familia y mis amigos para leer y
redactar documentos pero los semestres
se fueron complicando y ya la gente no
tenía tiempo
me habían hablado de algo llamado jobs
que era un lector de pantalla que
supuestamente les permitía a las
personas ciegas utilizar un computador
pero yo decía jesús puro cuento sin ver
la pantalla eso es imposible
sin embargo empecé a utilizar la dichosa
tecnología y esa voz de ellos que al
principio me parecía monótona canzona
terminaría por convertirse de ahí en
adelante en mi mayor aliada
hola soy 28 gusto
uso el computador y el celular como
cualquiera de ustedes tengo correo
electrónico de redes sociales como lo
pueden ver allí
leo y redactó documentos y hasta juego
también gracias a la tecnología
y logré mi mayor hazaña académica hasta
este momento
haber sido la primera persona con
discapacidad en colombia en ganar la
beca fulbright
no exagero cuando digo que el viaje de
los eeuu me cambió la vida
por primera vez salí del país y además
lo hice sola
se imaginarán lo difícil que fue esa
despedida en el aeropuerto
mis padres y hermanas veían partir a su
hija y hermana menor con discapacidad a
un país que está a kilómetros de
distancia
ya en el avión todo fue alegría y
expectativas
viaje en primera clase a las 10 de la
mañana
me sentía toda una viajera experta
y hasta pedido un cóctel
10 de la mañana
pero los últimos diez quince minutos de
vuelo cuando el avión inició sus
maniobras de aterrizaje
empiezo a sentir con un vacío en el
estómago
no por hambre
sino porque me entró un susto terrible
fui consciente de que nadie me iba a
estar esperando en ese aeropuerto
imagínense por unos segundos en un país
que no conocen si la posibilidad de ver
lo que sucede a su alrededor
y teniendo que confiar en extraños que
además hablan una lengua distinta a la
suya créanme que así uno sepa el idioma
hay momentos en los que uno no entiende
ni papa de lo que le están diciendo
eso pasa
mi estilo final fue la universidad de la
florida en gainesville
allí estudió la maestría en comunicación
tuve mi propio apartamento hice grandes
amigos sobre todo latinos éramos como
hermanitos éramos esa familia extendida
rumbia vamos y nos apoyamos en todo
también asiste a eventos donde conocí
becarios fulbright de todas partes del
mundo y fue algo muy enriquecedor algo
que le recomendaría a cualquiera de
ustedes tenga o no una discapacidad
porque se rompen muchos prejuicios hacia
la gente de otros países
no todo fue color de rosa tuve momentos
muy duros de los cuales quise devolverme
tirar la toalla porque no me sentía
capaz los que han estado lejos por algún
tiempo o por años sabrán lo que
significa extrañar hasta las cosas más
simples del país la comida las
conversaciones en la esquina el calor de
la gente un día estaba tan desesperada
que llamé a una amiga y le dije
yo mañana averiguó que hay que hacer
pero yo aquí no sigo esa es la versión
decente de lo que leí
además la exigencia académica era tanta
que pasaba días sin ver a mis amigos y
sin hablar con mi familia y mi novio
pero también vi momentos muy bonitos
celebra el día de acción de gracias
siendo el músico de cabecera con mis
amigos
gane un concurso de talentos y participe
en una versión del carnaval de
barranquilla con un grupo de colombianos
ahí estaba la música esa compañera
inseparable
dos años después concluye exitosamente
mi maestría y me fui a paseo por el sur
de la florida primero con vino y después
con mi familia conocimos los parques de
disney y universal
llegó el momento de volver a colombia y
aunque no lo crean también fue muy
difícil dejar ese apartamento que había
sido mi hogar por dos años fue duro
desde que estaba en eeuu venían
siguiéndole la pista mintic
y sabía que tenía unos proyectos muy
interesantes para la población con
discapacidad por lo llamado licencia
país y otro llamado cine para todos
y empecé a repetirme constantemente yo
quiero trabajar allá
sólo meses después y ahora parte del
equipo tics y discapacidad de la
dirección de apropiación
yo la que años antes había dicho que no
era posible para una persona ciega
utilizar un computador ahora liderada
convertir un proyecto pionero a nivel
mundial que cambiaría la vida de muchas
personas ciegas o con baja visión
permitiéndoles acceder gratuitamente a
las tecnologías
por fin muchas personas tendrían las
mismas oportunidades que yo había tenido
en otro proyecto me encargaron la
gestión de las redes sociales y me hacía
mucha gracia pensar que los usuarios al
otro lado no tenían ni idea que la
persona que publicaba contenidos a
diario y que respondía a sus inquietudes
no veía la pantalla
también puede la oportunidad de
representar a mintic en américa
accesible el evento de accesibilidad más
importante para la región de las
américas conocí brasil y intenté
aprender algo de portugués para
interactuar con la gente de una manera
más cercana al menos aprendí los saludos
hoy en día sigo trabajando por la
inclusión hago parte de la red de
mujeres con discapacidad visual que
agrupa mujeres de bogotá de distintos
departamentos del país
e incluso he incursionado en la radio
como locutora y realizadora pero
tranquilos que ya no daños los radios
intentando sacar los cantantes así que
no están ahí
recuerdan ese sueño frustrado el que les
habla el principio
pues les cuento que hace tres años
gracias a una exposición fotográfica que
hizo mi novio no puede cumplir fui
azafata por unas horas y no se imaginan
cómo lo disfruté
[Aplausos]
este es el mensaje que quiero dejarles
no permitan que el hecho de ser gordos
bajitos calvos una mala posición
económica el color de su piel o tener
una discapacidad defina quiénes son
ustedes o hasta dónde pueden llegar
yo soy más que unos ojos que no ven soy
una persona como ustedes con defectos y
virtudes que intentan cada día hacer de
este mundo un lugar mejor un lugar más
incluyente para todos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]